a new report in the medical journal the
lancet says there is a serious lack of
gender-specific research and data
when it comes to heart disease in women
heart disease as you may know is the
leading cause of death for
women globally the report recommends
more education on early detection for
health care providers
and the patients recruiting more women
for cardiac studies
and prioritizing research on heart
disease in women
cbs news senior medical correspondent
that's dr tara narula
met with a woman whose cardiac scared
during pregnancy
caught her by surprise
just weeks before her baby was due yulia
nurikan knew
something wasn't right i felt nauseous i
felt
dizzy and i felt like i was about to
face
concerned for the baby yulia rushed to a
local hospital in queens new york
where her daughter olivia was delivered
via emergency c-section
tests showed yulia had suffered an
aortic dissection
a potentially deadly tear in the lining
of the aorta
that affects blood flow to the body and
can potentially rupture the entire aorta
obviously if this happens then the
patient literally
dies instantly dr ismail el hamsi is an
aortic surgeon
at mount sinai hospital in manhattan
where yulia was taken for life-saving
surgery
leaving her newborn baby behind
after six days of only seeing olivia on
facetime calls
yulia finally got to hold her what did
it feel like to
hold her in your arms it felt like she
belonged there you say hi
had she not been pregnant julia says she
likely would have ignored her symptoms
and heart disease symptoms in women can
differ from those in men
rather than chest pain women sometimes
report indigestion
back pain or shortness of breath that's
one reason the authors of a new report
in the lancet say it is
critical to have more women's specific
studies
women are not small men we need to think
about women
as their own individual biology and
and come up with the answers for them
explain to us
how the current system is failing us
when it comes to research
and women we keep saying that we're
understudying
under recognizing under diagnosing these
women
and we need to make all kinds of efforts
to make sure that our
clinical trials have good representation
of women so when we have new devices new
drugs
the application is not just for men for
cbs this morning dr
tara narula new york